la saison estivale rime avec super
production et au québec
1 on vit en tête émile gaudreault au
cours de sa carrière plusieurs de ses
films ont franchi la barre des 6
millions de dollars de recettes des
succès qui s'accompagne d'une inévitable
pression c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
recette
j'ai pas de touche magique c'est la
seule solution de tout ça c'est de
travailler de travail de travail et que
tout est fragile
cette fois il raconte l'histoire de
mythomane qui voit ses mensonges
retourner contre lui
lorsque ces fabulation devienne réalité
fidèle émile gaudreault retrouve louis
josé houde pour une quatrième fois via
un petit côté vieux couple ou davantage
que si maintenant j'attends vraiment pas
de faire quelque chose ou si je trouve
quelque chose d'une mauvaise idée j'ai
fait une phase puis comprend des
bressans une relation qui s'enrichit
avec le teint faut que ça le film met en
vedette une impressionnante distribution
dont elisabeth aussi véronique le
flaguais et antoine bertrand qui incarne
le frère jumeau du personnage principal
interprété par louis josé houde
quand j'ai terminé le tournage on
prenait un verre le soir la dernière
journée puis j'allais voir emilie j'ai
dit ils feront faire un autre pas
nécessairement un menteur mais faut en
refaire un autre avec avec sept gagnants
avec louis-josé que je connais spots et
je pense qu'on a eu on a une super
connexion si on a une belle chimie à
l'écran nous sommes essayés
c'est quelqu'un que j'admire beaucoup je
pense qu'il ya un respect mutuel c'est
pourquoi nous on fait le pari audacieux
de confier le rôle féminin principal à
catherine chabot qui décroche son
premier rôle important au cinéma
ça a été un très long processus de
sélection a été quatre auditions
donc au bout de la troisième audition et
aimer le réalisateur mattel pour
l'examen quatrième ce sera pas toi
malheureusement les revenus et revenus
et la 4ème édition il ya improvisé
lecture josé pas le retrouver un peu
c'est le stress anc est difficile en
audition donc je suis là le retrouver
cette espèce de bonheur là deux joué on
a fait ses seuls personnages nous tous
les éléments clés sont réunis pour
séduire les foules
je pense qu'on a des aspirations ce que
ce fameux le soin vue
après ça pour quoi être déçu on se fait
pas d'eux serait pas de chiffres en tête
le je pense que je pense que si on a
fait notre job
les jambons volailles hellip la comédie
moteur remporté rethel le même succès
que les autres films d'emile gaudreault
c'est le public qui aura le dernier mot
la réponse le 10 juillet lors quelle
forme prendra l'affiché partout au
québec et syna by alexandre chartier
radio canada montréal